one of the exercises that they're now
going through you know they're only two
days away from their decision making is
that they came up with their own
priority areas that that Leslie just
enumerated and they're designing their
own metrics but in response to what you
said one of the things that was part of
their exercise is we left and Donna
Dubinsky suggested this that you leave
money aasai sort of discretionary
because you can get rigid in your
formulation and then having that
discretionary money allows you to then
think outside the box of what you could
find yourself that there are other
things that you think about
relationships their passions that aren't
justified in some metrics way but
deserve to be funded some of the most
meaningful giving that I've done has
just been something that hit me
personally one is a Chinese calligrapher
who lives in New Haven who's 99 years
old one of the best artists I mean one
of the best Chinese calligraphers alive
not just female calligraphers but one of
the best calligraphers alive and one
thing i did was i was able to preserve a
core of her work in the seattle art
museum and that actually was through my
own giving which it came from a very
deep personal connection and to me that
was that was incredibly rewarding